having your movies out in a pandemic um
has anyone had the chance to like ask
you for your autograph i mean
it's kind of weird because you're not
really out so have people really noticed
you anywhere i guess
do you know what i uh that hasn't really
happened yet like um
i haven't had a sign my first autograph
or anything but
just online i've kind of seen through uh
the critics and through social media
certain fans that
people have really been responding to
the work which is it's a nice feeling
yeah
wait are you saying that you haven't
actually signed an autograph yet
um i when i was a basketball player i
signed a couple for like kids and stuff
but no no i've never signed one for
acting
oh my gosh can i be your first will you
sign me i loved you in the movie will
you sign an autograph for me i'm gonna
put it
kelly is there any way because my
sister's i gotta say everything
wait kelly kelly i i all right i was
trying to play cool throughout the
interview but i gotta get out for a
second my sisters
and my parents and i we watch every
single episode of the first season of
american idol
so this is like so what i'm saying is
absolutely
justin or team kelly i'm just kidding
how about this how about this i i i've
seen the movie i've saw from justin the
couch
oh my god that was contractually
obligated night
wow i loved it my sisters and i loved it
we have a guest somewhere
uh but i love that y'all watch the first
season that's that's so cool
okay i i promise you this i'll sign
something for your family if you sign
something for me
my sisters and my mom will kill me if i
don't return so can we do like a little
trade-off is that is that cool
crazy okay and i'm not kidding next time
you come to my studio i'm gonna have it
like hanging up in the room you're in
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going